la internacional se escucha en el Museo
del louvre que esta mañana amaneció
cerrado los trabajadores sobre todo de
seguridad y de atención a las personas
se han plegado el movimiento en protesta
por la reforma de la jubilaciones
aprobada por el gobierno de Emmanuel
macron han dicho que este bloqueo se
mantendrá al menos durante todo el día
la respuesta ha sido variada en el
público sobre todo turistas que visitan
el museo más grande del mundo algunos de
ellos solidarizan con el movimiento
otros estaban más molestos Pues por
ahora la solución que da el museo es el
reembolso de los billetes escuchemos lo
que nos dijeron
compramos las entradas con anticipación
para venir alumbre hoy pero parece que
hay una protesta y nos dijeron que el
museo está cerrado en el momento
soy un poco decepcionada pero no hay
nada que pueda hacer para controlar la
situación
el mundo de la cultura se vio
particularmente
como una gran parte del servicio público
por ejemplo el Museo del louvre en la
revisión de políticas públicas y
modernización de la función pública
perdió unos 200 puestos a tiempo
completo en una década entonces la
primera reivindicación es la creación de
empleo y cuando se crean nuevas
cotizaciones sociales extras uno puede
permitirse reformar las jubilaciones
recordemos que mañana se espera un gran
movimiento social en Francia una nueva
huelga general en contra de este
proyecto que ya fue aprobado por el
gobierno de Emmanuel en macron es la
décima jornada y hoy el ambiente está
preparándose quizás para esa nueva
jornada de protestas con este movimiento
en el lubre pero también algunos
movimientos en las universidades
refinerías Y nuevamente los trabajadores
de la basura los recolectores que se han
vuelto a plegar a este movimiento mañana
Se espera que sea una huelga muy seguida
sobre todos los transportes y en la
educación un movimiento que la última
jornada se vio fortalecido y
rejuvenecido además con manifestaciones
que terminaron en muchos casos de manera
violenta